WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET STARTED
IT'S FOUR O'CLOCK AND I ONE
APOLOGIZE IS SO MUCH GOING ON
TODAY NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF THE
SESSION THAT WE HAD -- BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE CELEBRATION OF THE
HOLOCAUST -- AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT BECAUSE OF THE
HORRIFIC THING THAT HAPPENED.
AT THE IN SAN DIEGO THIS PAST
WEEKEND -- I HAD TO PARTICIPATE --
NEEDED TO PARTICIPATE IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT JUST TOOK PLACE --
THAT JUST ENDED MY UNDERSTAND
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS OF
MAKING OUR COMMITMENT -- TO OF
TO DO BETTER MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW IS THE
LEGISLATURE WE CAN SUPPORT OF
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE AND
SO -- WITH THAT HAVING BEEN SAID
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE FOR
WAITING FOR US -- WITH SO MANY
THINGS THAT ARE AGENDA AND SO
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST TO HEAR
YOU AS WELL AS TO WILL GIVE YOU
ALL THE MONEY YOU REQUESTED.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A PLAN THAT IT
IT HAD TO BE A MONOPOLY MONEY
BUT NONE THE LESS.
YOU CAN HAVE THAT -- BUT THAT
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST TO HEAR
YOU OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE YOU WAITED
TO TELL US YOUR STORY AND YOUR
NEEDS AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
A WITHIN THE FIRST WELL CALL
ROLE BECAUSE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND IN CASE SOMEONE WAS HAPPILY
YES.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THANK YOU.
I AND ALL OF OUR MEMBERS IN
MULTITUDES OF COMMITTEES AND SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY WILL
EVENTUALLY GET THROUGH HERE.
THIS IS NOT AN AGENDA WERE
VOTING ON ANYTHING BUT WE DO
WANT TO HEAR YOU BECAUSE WE WILL
BE VOTING FAIRLY SOON ABOUT THE
ON THE VARIOUS ISSUES SO GUN
BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE WHICH IS --
OF CALIFORNIA JOB CHALLENGE
ACADEMY AND DISCOVER CHALLENGE
AT ACT ACADEMY EXPANSION THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR WAITING AND
FOR BEING HERE.
THANK THANK YOU BETTER GET YOUR
MEMBERS IT IS THE SO OUT OF IS
IT OKAY IF I BEGIN WITH THE
YOUTH CHALLENGE PROGRAM WHY NOT.
SO THAT'S THE THE SECOND BUDGET
ITEM IT'S THERE THE SECOND PART
OF IF ISSUE.
ONE AND ITS TO EXPAND IN
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT.
WE STARTED THREE YEARS AGO DOWN
IN LATER OF WHICH IS NEAR
STOCKTON.
CALIFORNIA IT'S OUR THIRD
CHALLENGE PROGRAM.
IN A OBVIOUSLY OUR NEWEST AND
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR
CHALLENGE PROGRAMS -- WE HAVE
ONE IN LOS ALAMEDA IS ON OUR
MILITARY BASE THERE WE HAVE ONE
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO AT A MILITARY
BASE THERE AND THEN.
ON A NEW MILITARY BASE AT THAT
WE JUST ACQUIRED IN LES
THROUGHOUT -- THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE AIMED.
AT GETTING AT RISK YOU THESE ARE
HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUTS OR FOR HIGH
SCHOOLERS WHO ARE A SEMESTER OR
YEAR BEHIND WHO HAVE A ZERO
POINT.
SOMETHING GPA AND WHO WILL DROP
OUT IF SOMETHING ISN'T DONE --
THEY VOLUNTEER TO COME TO OUR
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS IN EACH OF
THESE LOCATIONS WHICH MEANS THEY
LIVE WITH US WE ARE THERE LEGAL
GUARDIANS.
AFTER THE SIX MONTHS THAT THEY
STAY WITH US THEY WERE UNIFORMS
THEY ARE -- THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
VERY STRICT DISCIPLINARIAN BUYER
MEANT -- THAT IS MODEL THAT IS --
MODELED AFTER OF A MILITARY
EDUCATION MODEL.
IT'S EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE THE
BOYS AND THE GIRLS ARE SEPARATED
THE AT THE ONLY SEE EACH OTHER
WHEN THEY PASS EACH OTHER IN
FORMATION.
THEY GO TO SCHOOL ALL DAY
THERE'S MANDATORY STUDY PERIODS
WE TEACH THEM HOW TO EAT MANY OF
THEM DON'T KNOW HOW TO EAT A
NUTRITIOUS WHAT A NUTRITIOUS
MEAL LOOKS LIKE MANY OF THEM
DON'T KNOW HOW TO EXERCISE.
PROPERLY MANY OF THEM DON'T HAVE
COPING SKILLS -- AND SO THEY
ADDRESS -- PROBLEMS IN THEIR OWN
LIVES IN COUNTERPRODUCTIVE WAYS
WE TEACH THEM HOW TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS IN THEIR LIVES IN
PRODUCTIVE WAYS.
WE CARE ABOUT THEM AND WE MENTOR
THEM AND THIS IS ALL DONE AROUND
THE CLOCK BY OUR MILITARY CADRE.
THIS IS THE FEDERAL STATE COUNTY
PARTNERSHIP OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PAYS 75% OF THE
OPERATING COSTS THE STATE PAYS
25%.
THE COUNTY IS THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION ESTABLISH AN OLD
ALTERNATIVE HIGH SCHOOL AND I
PROVIDE TEACHERS CURRICULUM
BOOKS AND ALL OF THE OTHER
MATERIALS -- THAT YOU WOULD IN
AN ORDINARY HIGH SCHOOL THIS ONE
JUST HAPPENS TO BE A RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM.
THE OUTCOMES ARE EXTRAORDINARY
BOTH IN TERMS OF GIVING THESE.
AT RISK YOUTH SECOND CHANCE AT
LIFE -- MANY OF THEM -- WELL NOT
MANY OF THEM ABOUT A THIRD --
ABOUT A QUARTER TO A THIRD
GRADUATE WHILE THEY'RE AT THE
PROGRAM THEY TYPICALLY.
GET ABOUT A YEAR'S WORTH OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN JUST SIX MONTHS AND SO
IF THEY DON'T GRADUATE AND THEY
GET CAUGHT UP WITH THEIR PEERS.
THEY GO BACK TO THEIR HIGH
SCHOOLS THEIR PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS -- AND THEY TYPICALLY
HAVE THREE POINT FIVE FOUR POINT
NO STATE KNOW HOW TO STUDY THEY
KNOW HOW TO SUCCEED AND THEY
HAVE HOPE AGAIN.
AND THEY KNOW THAT IF THEY A
STAY ON THE PATH WILL SUCCEED.
THE THE THE PCP OR THE I'M SORRY
THE BUDGET ITEM PROPOSES
EXPANDING THE DISCOVERY
CHALLENGE PROGRAM.
IN LATE THROUGHOUT -- BY
PROVIDING AN EXTRA PLATOON SO
THERE'S THERE'S FOUR PLATOONS IN
A FULLY MATURE CHALLENGE PROGRAM.
DISCOVERY BECAUSE IT'S SO NEW
ONLY HAS THREE THIS WOULD ADD
THE FOURTH AND FINAL PLATOON --
IT'S A TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL 75% OF WHICH IS
FOR FEDERAL TRUST FUND THAT'S
ONE POINT SIX FIVE MILLION.
AND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
IN GENERAL FUND AND FIFTEEN
POSITIONS.
SO MAYBE I'LL JUST TAKE
QUESTIONS IF THAT'S OKAY WITH A
CHAIR ON YOURS PROPANE ONE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WELL LET ME FIND
IF THERE'S ANY COMMENTS FROM.
FINANCE ARE LA ALL.
FONG CRISTINA CONCERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL OKAY FINE IN A CUT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
OKAY WHAT DID YOU SAY YOUR
SUCCESS RATE WAS I SHOULD -- SO
WE WE STRIVE TO ACHIEVE THAT 90%
GRADUATION RATE FROM THE
CHALLENGE PROGRAM.
THE STUDENTS ARE THEN -- MAN
TOWARD BY A CERTIFIED MENTOR AND
TRACKED FOR TWELVE MONTHS AFTER
THEY GRADUATE -- BUT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GRADUATE BETWEEN NINETY
AND I AND A 100% -- OF OUR OF
THE STUDENTS SINCE.
AT NINETEEN NINETY THREE IS WHEN
WE OPENED OUR FIRST CHALLENGE
PROGRAM OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM AFTER THE
MENTORSHIP.
FOR A YER SO.
SO WE WE KIND OF LOSE TRACK OF
AFTER THEY FINISH THEIR TWELVE
MONTH MENTORSHIP PROGRAM WHICH
IS WHY.
THE THE SECOND ITEM THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING WHICH IS THE JOBS
PROGRAM FITS RIGHT IN IT'S IT'S
REALLY.
A PHASE TWO TO THE CHALLENGE
PROGRAM OKAY AND ALLOWS US TO
THAT AND NOT ONLY -- PROVIDE
THEM.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET A COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
BUT ANOTHER YEAR OF TRACKING AND
MENTOR SHIP FOLLOWING THEIR
GRADUATION.
NOW THESE STUDENTS I STILL COME
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE.
YES MA'AM ALL OVER THE STATE
EVERY EVERY CALIFORNIA STUDENT
IS ELIGIBLE ARE THEY REFERRED
THERE ARE THEY VOLUNTEER OUT OF
THE FIND OUT.
A LOT OF INVOLVED AND FIND OUT
FROM THEIR FROM THEIR CLASSMATES
AND FROM THEIR FRIENDS THAT'S
WHAT WE FIND WITH THE MATCH THE
LA AND ON THE CENTRAL COAST.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING
WORK JUST GETS OUT BY WORD OF
MOUTH.
THE DISCOVERY PROGRAM -- BECAUSE
IT'S ONLY THREE YEARS OLD WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A TEAM OF
RECRUITERS THAT GO TO HIGH
SCHOOLS AND TALK TO A COUNSELOR
STOCKTON EVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
WHO CAN VOUCH FOR THE THE
VALIDITY OF THE PROGRAM?
AND RECOMMEND STUDENTS BUT
STUDENTS MUST VOLUNTEER AND
THEIR PARENTS MUST SIGN A
ESSENTIALLY -- A GUARDIANSHIP A
DOCUMENT SO -- THE MOST THE MOST
IMPORTANT CHARACTERISTIC OF A
SUCCESSFUL CHALLENGE ACADEMY
STUDENTS IS THAT THEY'RE
MOTIVATED HUNTER BECAUSE IT'S
TOUGH.
AND AND THEN WE DO OUR BEST TO
TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THOSE TIMES
WHEN THEY STRUGGLE AND THEY WILL
THEY WILL GET HOME SICK.
THEY WILL.
YOU KNOW GET DISCOURAGED THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT FOLKS THERE TO TO
KEEP THE MEN IN THE PROGRAM AND
SO WE'VE.
WE'VE.
DONE BETTER THAN ANY OTHER STATE
THAT HAS THIS PROGRAM ISN'T
GRADUATING THAT.
OKAY WANT TO GIVE US A SECOND
PROPOSAL YES OF THE JOBS
CHALLENGE PROGRAM IS BRAND NEW.
BECAUSE WE'VE ALWAYS KINDA KNOWN
THAT -- THE THE THE THE PROBLEM
I THINK THAT YOU IDENTIFIED WE
HAVE THIS THIS THIS REMARKABLE.
A PROGRAM THAT PREPARES THEM TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
BUT WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER THEY GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY GET OUT WHAT YOU KNOW
PREVAILING WAGE JOB IF THEY YOU
KNOW KIND OF FALL BACK INTO OLD
HABITS.
A LOT OF THEM COME FROM FROM.
HOME SITUATIONS THAT ARE JUST
NOT IDEAL AND SO -- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TESTED A PROGRAM
CALLED THE JOBS CHALLENGE
PROGRAM. TO OFFER A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THESE CHALLENGE
GRADUATES ONE SAVE -- GOT THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RE ENROLL INTO A
RESIDENT PROGRAM.
AT THIS ONE WILL BE IN LOS
ANGELES AT OUR AT OUR LOS
ALAMEDA'S LOCATION.
AND IN THE SAME TYPE OF MILITARY
ENVIRONMENT ATTEND -- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHAT'S THAT WE PARTNERED
WITH CHIU COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
I WANT TO GET THESE NAMES RIGHT --
CYPRESS COLLEGE AND LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THE CLASS OF SEVENTY FIVE AND
WE'RE GOING -- TO THEY'LL BE
TRANSPORTED TO THESE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHERE THEY WILL.
GO THROUGH CURRICULUM -- FOR
CYBER -- YOU KNOW I. T. CYBER --
CURRICULUM AUTOMOTIVE AND
CONSTRUCTION.
AND THEY'LL BE IN IN CLASS WITH
STILL OTHERS OTHER CHALLENGE
THERE OTHER JOBS CHALLENGE
STUDENTS SO THEY WON'T BE MIXED
IN WITH.
WITH OTHER -- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE WANT HIM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET.
BUT THE TYPE OF THE TYPE OF
EXPERIENCE IN WHICH THEY CAN
SUCCEED.
SO THEY GET TRANSPORTED BACK AND
FORTH THEY HAVE THE SAME A
SUPPORT NETWORK SO -- THEY'RE
FED IF THEY'RE LOOK AFTER
MATHEMATICALLY -- AGAIN THEY
CONTINUE TO EXERCISE AND EAT
RIGHT AND THEY CONTINUE CONTINUE
TO BE MEN TOWARD AN AND TUTORED.
AND ENSURE THAT -- THOSE THAT
ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY HELPED.
AND THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET THEM
THROUGH THESE COURSES AND AND
INTO A PER MAIL INTO A LIVING
WAGE JOBS SO EITHER INTO AN
APPRENTICESHIP OR JUST RIGHT
INTO -- INTO A BUSINESS THAT
PROVIDES THEM OUT.
A JOB THAT THEY CAN LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY ON WE WANT.
TO KEEP FROM HAVING TO GO BACK
HOME.
HOW LONG IS THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM TWENTY TWO WEEKS OF
MONEY -- WEEKS ALL OF THESE ARE
TWENTY TWO WEEKS LONG -- SO WILL
GRADUATE EACH CHALLENGE PROGRAM
WILL GRADUATE -- FOUR HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT DISCOVERY AS WELL
WHEN IT'S FULLY -- FULLY MATURE
AND THEN THE THE JOBS CHALLENGE
PROGRAM WILL BEGIN AT SEVENTY
FIVE AND PROBABLY GROW TO A TWO
HUNDRED STUDENTS A YEAR -- AND
SO IT'LL BE ARE I'M SORRY A
HUNDRED STUDENTS PER PER TWENTY
TWO WEEK UHHUH CURRICULUM -- SO
IT'LL BE TOO HIGH -- HUNDRED
FIFTY BETWEEN ITEM FIFTEEN TWO
HUNDRED WHEN IT'S FULLY MATURE.
SO THAT THE FACILITIES ARE
ALREADY READY TO GO -- ON ON
THEIR FARM FEDERAL MILITARY BASE --
THIS MONEY WHICH IS PAY FOR THAT
THE CADRE -- WE'VE ALREADY GOT --
ALL OF THE ARRANGEMENTS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN PLACE.
THEY THEY LOVE THE PROGRAM THEY
WANT TO BE PART OF IT AND I
THINK WE'LL FIND MORE.
OF THESE TYPES OF IN STORING
INSTITUTIONS AS THE PROGRAM
GROWS WHICH JUST GIVE WILL GIVE
THE STUDENTS MORE OPPORTUNITIES
A GREATER MENU OF OF OF
CURRICULA.
DON'T GREAT ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS LA -- FINANCE -- OKAY
WE JUST HAD A QUICK COMMENT ON
THIS -- SO WE DO THINK THAT THIS --
PROGRAM IS CERTAINLY PROMISING
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN TRIED
BY THREE STATES BUT JUST JUST
FOR A FEW YEARS.
ON THIS AND THEN IT WILL BE NEW
TO CALIFORNIA AND SO I'M I'M
LIKE THE YOUTH CHALLENGE PROGRAM
THAT YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT
BECAUSE THIS IS SO NEW THERE IS
A PRETTY LIMITED INFORMATION ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS.
I'M CERTAINLY IT'S VERY
PROMISING CERTAINLY WE EXPECT TO
HAVE -- WE WE VERY MUCH HOPE TO
HAVE THESE THESE OUTCOMES SO WE
DO THINK IT'S WORTH I'M HAVING
THE DEPARTMENT I'M PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION ON
ITS PLANS TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND TRACK THE
EFFECTIVENESS BECAUSE I THINK.
THE CHAIR GOT TO REALLY ONE OF
THE CREEK CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF
ON THIS KIND OF PROGRAM IS YOUR
PROMISES ALL THESE GREAT THINGS
AND WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE WE'RE GETTING ALL OF THOSE
SUCCESSES AND AND ESPECIALLY
THAT WE DON'T LOSE TRACK OF THE
STUDENTS -- AFTER THEY LEAVE THE
PROGRAM AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY OUR MAIN -- RIGHT OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC CONCERNING THIS
PROPOSAL ANYONE IN THE PROS
[inaudible]
MANY CONS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OKAY SOUNDS EXCITING.
I HOPE IT WORKS WE WOULD LIKE TO
PROBABLY GET REPORTS BACK. TO
SEE HOW IT GOES IN TERMS OF
RECRUITMENT -- WOULD LIKE TO I'D
LIKE TO KNOW THE DIVERSITY OF
THE GROUP THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
UP AND FROM WHAT WHAT AREAS OF
MAKING SURE REACHING THOSE.
HARD TO REACH AREAS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF OPTIONS -- BUT IT SOUNDS
EXCITING -- AND YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL WORK.
MILITARY TO PASS USED TO WORK
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE I KNOW WE
BECAME VERY SELECTING PICKING
FOLKS AND AND AS A RESULT OF
WE'VE MISSED OUT ON A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE VOICE TO SING.
THAN A YOUNG MAN TO THE MILITARY
TO BECOME A MAN.
AND THEN WE CHANGE THAT AND UP
TO OUR STANDARDS FOR ADMISSION
AND WE LEFT A LOT OF KIDS WHO.
PROBABLY COULD HAVE USED A
STRUCTURE SO THIS WILL HOPEFULLY
WILL BE HELPFUL AND LOOK FOR TO
THE EXCITEMENT OF IT AND THE THE
RESULTS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
EXCITED [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WOULD NOT ITEM TO WHICH
DEALS WITH -- JUDICIAL BRANCH.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR WAITING
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER AND
NUMBERS TO MY NAME IS LOT
COMPUTER WHICH FROM THE BUDGET
DIRECTOR FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I'M HERE -- TO BRIEFLY --
EXPLAIN OUR PROPOSAL I HAVE A
OUR DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES MY
ACCORDING TO GIVE YOU A BIT MORE
BACKGROUND ON IT -- AS THE THE
CHEN DOES A GREAT JOB OF THE
GIVING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSALS -- THE NEW INDIA
JUVENILE AND FAMILY --
COURTHOUSE AS WELL AS THE NEW EL
CENTRO COURTHOUSES -- HAVE
EXPECTED COSTS -- BASED ON OUR
BIDS BEYOND WHAT IS IN INCLUDING
THE BUDGET IN THE THE AGENDA
DOES A GOOD JOB THEN I COULD
TURN IT.
TO MISTER COURTNEY TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE BACKGROUND ON ON
WHAT'S GOING ON WHAT'S DRIVING
THOSE COST INCREASES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MEMBERS
SO THAT THE TWO PROJECTS WERE
PUT OUT TO BID -- EACH OF THEM
CAME IN IN EXCESS OF THE
AUTHORIZED APPROPRIATIONS.
OF THE CONTRIBUTING FACTORS WERE
THE REMOTENESS OF THE LOCATION
OF ALL PROJECTS -- EVEN THOUGH
THERE IS A LOT OF POPULATION IN
THOSE AREAS FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE THEY'RE CONSIDERED
REMOTE -- CURRENT BUSINESS
CLIMATE.
OF THIS VERY -- MARKET IS VERY
HOT RIGHT NOW THE CONTRACTORS OR
CAN BE VERY SELECTIVE ABOUT
PROJECTS THEY WOULD CONSIDER
WORKING ON AND THERE'S A HIGH
DEMAND FOR LABOR.
ALL THOSE FACTORS CONTRIBUTE TO
INCREASE COSTS FOR SOME
FORTUNATELY -- HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
ANY COMMENT FROM LA -- OR
FINANCE OKAY.
IN A MEMBERS QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING -- AND
AND I UNDERSTAND THIS AT THE
COSTUME INCREASES THEIR WHEN WE
FINISHED -- THE NEW ADDITION TO
OUR AIRPORT -- MAYBE ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO FIVE SIX YEARS AGO ARE
ARE A DIRECTOR OF AIRPORT SAID
THAT TO WE CAME IN -- AHEAD OF
TIME AND UNDER BUDGET AND
EVERYBODY'S LIKE WHAT AND SHE
SAYS WELL BECAUSE EVERYBODY
NEEDS A JOB NOW SO WE CAN
NEGOTIATE. FOR A LOT LESS AND
PEOPLE WERE SELLING MATERIALS
THAT LOT LESS BECAUSE THEY HAD
ACCESS BECAUSE NO ONE WAS
BUILDING AT THE TIME.
AND MOST OF A SHUT DOWN OUR
BUILDING EFFORTS BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY WHEN IT
REALLY WAS THE OPPORTUNE TIME TO
BE TO DO THE WORK AND SHE
RECOGNIZE THAT AT THE AIRPORT.
SO WE CAME IN AHEAD OF TIME
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS LOOKING
FOR A JOB SO WE HAD LOTS OF
FOLKS.
AND WE CAME IN UNDER BUDGET
BECAUSE PEOPLE WILLING TO SELL
THE MATERIALS A LOT LESS BECAUSE
THEY HAD EXCESS MATERIAL AND NO
ONE WAS BUYING.
SO IT'S KIND OF IT IT'S NOT THE
CASE TODAY YEAH THIS IS THIS
KIND OF REVERSE THINKING YOU
KNOW THAT YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THAT IT WOULD BE.
EXPENSIVE AT THAT TIME BUT IT
REALLY WAS IN SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED SO I
UNDERSTAND.
THE DEMAND NOW -- FOR FOR LOTS
OF PROJECTS AND PEOPLE CAN BE
SELECT WHICH IS A GOOD THING I
GUESS NOT FOR US BUT FIFTEEN
RIGHT.
OKAY NEED ANY COMMENTS FROM --
AUDIENCE ANYONE IN FAVOR ANYONE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK THANK
YOU HELLO.
WITHOUT THIRD ITEM WHICH IS
EARLY -- EARTHQUAKE WARNING
SYSTEM
.
OKAY THANK YOU.
TOP OF THE START WITH THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
SIXTEEN PEAK POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND FOR THE
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING PROGRAM.
TO COMPLETE ANY ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES STILL OUTSTANDING
WITH ME TODAY IS TINA CURRY TO
PROVIDE.
AN OVERVIEW IN -- FOR FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- AN INTEREST
OF TIME I CAN JUST FILL YOU IN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
WITH THIS.
PROGRAM SO FAR THERE'S BEEN A
COUPLE OF CONFUSIONS OF OF
FUNDING FOR THIS SO FAR AND AND
THEN OF COURSE AND ASK ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
SO THERE'S BASICALLY THESE
COMPONENTS TO THIS EARTHQUAKE
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM IT'S
GETTING THE EARTHQUAKE SENSORS
INTO THE GROUND WE HAD
INVESTMENT OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND IN FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN MOST OF THAT
WORKS COMPLETED THAT GOT US
ABOUT -- HALFWAY THROUGH WHAT WE
HAVE LEFT TO DO TOWARDS GETTING
A THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN SENSORS
IN THE GROUND AND WITH -- FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE.
PRETTY MUCH COMPLETE THAT BUILD
OUT THE PROPOSAL AS TAB AT THE
STATE IT IS TO FUND -- ANYWAY
SOME REMAINING ONE TIME COSTS
INCLUDING A PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD BE ABOUT
HALF OF IT -- IS FAR AS ROLLING
OUT THE SYSTEM WE WERE
SUCCESSFULLY ABLE TO TEST THE
SYSTEM OVER THE WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERT IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND JUST THIS PAST MARCH.
AND THE RESULT OF THAT WERE VERY
PROMISING AND WE FOUND THAT OVER
HALF OF THE RECIPIENTS WERE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THE ALERT WITH THE
WITH UNDER TEN SECONDS WHICH WAS.
WHICH WAS A GOOD RESULT -- WE
BUT LIKE IT TO BE BETTER WE
WOULD LIKE TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE
OTHER HALF -- BUT THAT DOES
APPEAR TO BE PROMISING AND ALSO --
WE'RE PLANNING ON WE FEEL THAT
THAT CENTER NETWORK IN THE
SYSTEM IS ROBUST ENOUGH THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BEGIN THE ROLL
OUT OF THIS TO THE PUBLIC WITH
WE AND OTHER ALERT MECHANISMS --
HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR AND THEN FINALLY WE WERE WE
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY AN UPDATE TO OUR
BUSINESS PLAN WHICH IS REQUIRED
ANNUALLY.
AND THAT INCLUDED A SUMMARY OF
THE OF THE ITEMS I JUST
DESCRIBED AND ALSO TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SUSTAINMENT
FUNDING FOR THE FUTURE AND WHAT
WHAT SOURCES WE MIGHT LOOK.
TO I'M WITHOUT SOME HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT
THE BUSINESS PLAN ABOUT THE
SYSTEM ROLLOUT -- THAT -- THAT
YOU HAVE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM LA -- SO WE WE
KNOW THIS IS ONE OF A FEW
REQUESTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT IT
DOESN'T HAVE A WRITTEN PROPOSAL --
WE DO WE DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH
CONTINUING TO FIND THESE ONE
TIME COSTS -- WE WOULD NOTE TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE THINK
ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS THAT'S
BEFORE YOU IS -- WHAT FUNDING
SOURCE TO USE NOT JUST THIS YEAR
BUT ON AN ONGOING BASIS SO AS
THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONS ON THERE
ARE GONNA BE SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
MAINTAINING AN OPERATING THAT
SYSTEM?
THEY DO YOU HAVE -- A BUSINESS
PLAN THAT'S PROVIDED A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS ON THAT THEY
ARE THAT THEY THINK ARE THE MOST
PROMISING AYE THOSE INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE -- INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY SERVICE WHICH CHARGES ON
RATE PAYERS -- TRANSPORTATION --
PROVIDERS THAT WOULD BE LIKE
PARK OR OTHER RAIL LINES -- OR
ALSO CHARGES ON CELL PHONE BILLS
I'M SO I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY
WORTHWHILE THAT THEY'VE PROVIDED --
THAT INFORMATION WE DO THINK
HOWEVER THAT -- SOME MORE
DETAILS WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS IT WEIGHS ON LONG
TERM WHAT IT'S GONNA WANT TO DO --
FOR EXAMPLE IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY
WHAT THE MECHANISMS WILL BE TO
ATTACK US AS THOSE CHARGES IF --
YOU THEY HAVE BEEN THE DETAILS
HAVE BEEN WORKED OUT YET -- AND
FOR EXAMPLE IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY
HOW MUCH TO YOU KNOW WHO'S GONNA
PAY HOW MUCH WHETHER ALL OF
THOSE WILL BE A COULD WILL
ULTIMATELY BE IMPLEMENTED OR
MAYBE ONLY A SUBSET OF THOSE
CHARGES ARE.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST UNCLEAR AT
THIS POINT -- WE DO KNOW ALSO
THAT -- REALLY THE DECISIONS
THIS YEAR COULD COULD BE PRETTY
IMPORTANT -- BECAUSE IT MIGHT
TAKE A WHILE FOR THOSE CHARGES
TO ACTUALLY GET UP AND AND BE
AVAILABLE FOR YOU SO I WE THINK
IT'S WHAT.
WE DO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ASK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON THE
SPECIFICS OF ITS PLAN. FOR A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THIS BECAUSE WHILE THERE'S I
CERTAINLY RATIONALE FOR USING
GENERAL FUND THERE'S ALSO SOME
RATIONALE FOR THESE OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES AND LEGISLATURE
WANT TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION AS
IT'S CONSIDERING THIS PROPOSAL.
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT.
ANY THINKING YEAH WELL
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE WORKING OUT
THOSE DETAILS WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO SHARE THOSE WITH USE OF IT
WITH YOU IS AS PROGRESS AS AND
WE SET UP THAT MORE LONG TERM
SORT OF BUDGET INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR THIS BUT ONE THING THAT WE
WE HAVE FOUND IN WORKING WITH
THE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT WE WE
FOCUSED ON IN THE BUSINESS PLAN
IS THAT THERE'S ALREADY
INVESTMENT BEING MADE INTO
EARTHQUAKE SAFETY AND EARTHQUAKE
RISK MITIGATION WE BELIEVE THIS
IS ANOTHER TOOL. FOR EARTHQUAKE
RISK MINUTE DATE BASIC
MEDICATION AND HOW CAN THE COST
OF THIS BE OFFSET PERHAPS ARE
INCLUDED WITHIN THOSE EXISTING.
INVESTMENTS FOR EARTHQUAKE
SAFETY AND KIND OF USING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALREADY
THERE OKAY WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING THAT THEM OKAY ANY
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
STUDENTS IN THE PART OF FINANCE
JUST WOULD TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS THE DEPARTMENT AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT.
ENTITIES THAT STAND TO BENEFIT
FROM THE SYSTEM WITH ITS UP AND
RUNNING AND SO TO KIND OF WORK
THROUGH THE DETAILS OF WHAT THE
BEST WAY IS TO ASSESS YOU KNOW A
FEE FOR A LONG TERM FUNDING --
HOWEVER WE DECIDE TO GO ABOUT
DOING THAT A LOT OF THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT TALK ABOUT WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT HARD -- AND YOU
KNOW AS SOON AS WE HAVE DETAILS
THAT ARE READY TO COME FORWARD.
HAPPY.
TO SHARE THOSE AND DISCUSS THEM
WITH AND STUFF ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY ANY COMMONSENSE YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
OF FOR THE ITEM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. TO THIS REQUEST IS
FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO SUPPORT
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROGRAM.
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF OF
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BEGINNING
EN TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WE
RECEIVE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AS ONE TIME
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE EXCEPT FOR IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WHEN IT WAS
REDUCED. ONE TIME TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS SUPPORTS
TWENTY ONE PROJECTS STATE WIDE
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAD GINA
BOUCHERIE HERRINGTON. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEY COMING FROM LA -- WE JUST
KNOW THIS IS ANOTHER PROPOSAL
THAT LACKS -- ABOUT TO CHANGE
PROPOSAL -- AND THE ABSENCE OF
THAT IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVELS OF
FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO FIND IT MORE OR
POTENTIALLY LESS THAN THIS
AMOUNT.
ADDITIONALLY -- THERE IS ANOTHER
QUESTION OF FUNDING SOURCE I
CERTAINLY THE GENERAL FUND IS AN
OPTION HOWEVER -- IT'S ALSO
POSSIBLE THAT SOME OF THE TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES MIGHT -- QUALIFY
FOR SOME FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL --
SO ANYTHING THAT'S A DIRECT
SERVICE TO VICTIMS -- COULD
POTENTIALLY BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
FEDERAL FUNDS.
IT COVERS FOR FINANCE JUST WITH
ECHO IT WITH THE INTRODUCTION
WAS NOT THAT THE AMOUNT THAT STE
A PROPOSED HERE IS BASED ON
CONTINUING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINED TO INVEST PREVIOUSLY
AND SO THAT'S REALLY THE A NEXUS
BEHIND HOW WE ARRIVED AT THAT
AMOUNT AND DECIDE TO CONTINUE
WITH.
THAT LEVEL OKAY.
IS THERE ANY DATA THAT YOU HAVE
CONCERNING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAMS ABSOLUTELY.
I'M OVER THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS -- THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VICTIMS SERVED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS SERVICES TEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE TO
BE EXACT. TO DATE AND OF THOSE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO THOSE WAS
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
THOUSAND FORTY EIGHT AND THOSE
ARE BOTH LABOR AND SEX.
TRAFFICKING.
LOCAL.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED CRISIS
COUNSELING IN PERSON IN PERSON
COUNSELING GROUP COUNSELING CASE
MANAGEMENT SHELTER SERVICES
TRANSPORTATION LEGAL ASSISTANCE.
AND REFERRALS TO OTHER SERVICES
SO WHEN YOU DEAL WITH TEN
THOUSAND PLUS VICTIMS TO SAVE
LEVIN THOUSAND VICTIMS YOU'RE
SAYING OF THAT. ELEVEN THOUSAND
BUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ELEMENTS OF SERVICE WAS PROVIDED
TO THEM SO ONE PERSON MIGHT GET
TEN MULTIPLE SERVICE YES OKAY.
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY -- DATA ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS IN TERMS OF
NOT ONLY PROVIDING SERVICES BUT
FOLKS NOT COMING BACK AGAIN OR
DO NO BETTER.
WE DON'T DO NOT HAVE THAT IDEA
OKAY YEAH I KNOW THAT'S AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE BECAUSE IT'S A
VERY I SERVED ON THE BOARD ONCE.
FOR BATTERED WOMEN SERVICES AND
AND I KNOW.
IT'S IT'S A DIFFICULT -- THAT TO
CRACK CAN YOU.
TRYING TO BREAK THROUGH OF
PEOPLES -- MENTALITY WITH
REGARDS TO BEING INDEPENDENT.
AND NOT FALLING BACK INTO THE
SAME TRAPS AGAIN SO IT SOMETIMES
TAKES MULTIPLE TIMES OF GOING
BACK AND FORTH WHEN WE DID.
A SPARE SHELTERS TO FIGHT TO GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THEM AND A CHANGE
THE DIRECTION OF THEIR LIVES.
IT'S NOT AN EASY TASK YEAH AND
SEE.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE TO ANYONE IN FAVOR OF
AHA I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE SET SO
LONG THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
THANK YOU IN THE COURTROOM AND
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
GRANT RECIPIENTS HAVE FOUND THIS
FUNDING TO BE REALLY HELPFUL FOR
VICTIMS WHO ARE TRYING TO
REINTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING MELANIE QUIT AS
WITH KING HOW IT'S AN APARTMENT
ON BEHALF OF CAST THE COALITION
TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
SPONSORS OF THEIR QUESTIONS CAN
REMEMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VERY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM WE FOUND --
BUILDING A TEAM OF FOLKS WHO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THE VICTIMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN FAMILY
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT SPEAKING IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CUSTOMS LIKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
ANY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT BRINGS IS NOW TO OUR LOCAL
AND STATE PUBLIC SAFETY
PROPOSALS.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THEM
THIS THE FLORA IS HERE.
WANTING TO PRESENT TWO OF HIS
RIPPLES ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE
DONE THIS YEAR -- AND I THINK WE
DID A LITTLE BIT LESS YOU'RE
TALKING TRYING TO REMEMBER
MEMBERS OFTEN -- HAVE PROPOSALS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FUNDING
OF VARIOUS THINGS AND SOMETIMES
THE CHEER JUST TAKES IT MAKES
THE DECISION OF WHAT TO DO AND
MOVE ON I TRY TO GIVE OUR
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BEFORE US AND TO PRESENT.
IN A VERY BRIEF MATTER THEIR
PROPOSAL SO YOU HEAR IT AND HAVE
BEEN MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT THEY CAN ASK.
WE ASK NOT THAT WE WILL WE'LL
LET THE AUDIENCE EVENTUALLY
RESPOND TO THEM AT THE END OF
ALL THE PROPOSALS BUT I DID WANT
TO MEMBERS TO OF THE OF THE
ASSEMBLY TO HAVE ACCESS TO US.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SAID.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION REQUESTING TO TO
CREATE A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
GRANT PROGRAM IN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THIS GRANT THAT TEND TO MAKE IT --
OP ABILITY TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE.
U. K. THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES.
AS WELL WHERE THE ACTIVE SHOOTER
INTO THE CROSS THE NATION ARE
INCREASING AN ALARMING RATE.
IN A LACK OF AFFECTING CLEAR
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THOSE IN DANGER
PROVEN TO BE A SHORTCOMING THAT
IS UNFORTUNATELY.
BEEN PREVALENT IN ALL OF THESE
KANNST BECAUSE CATASTROPHES BY
EQUIPPING OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
WITH INTER OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGIES.
WOULD ALLOW OUR FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS TO TAKE CONTROL THE
CRISIS AT HAND THIS REQUEST IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
SAVE STUDENT LIVES IN CALIFORNIA
NOT FROM ACTIVE SHOOTERS BUT
FROM ANY POTENTIAL HARM TO MAKE
COME IN.
IN THEIR WAY WHILE AT SCHOOL
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
JOHN LEVEL IN MOUNT STERLING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JOHN LEVEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA --
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WERE SPONSORS
OF A BILL IN THE SAME SUBJECT
MATTER AREA.
THAT PASSED OUT OF ASSEMBLY GEO
THIS LAST WEEK ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE.
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS ARE --
BECOMING NORMALIZED LAST YEAR'S
NATIONAL STATISTICS ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENT ON A K. THROUGH --
TWELVE SCHOOL ONCE EVERY FIVE
DAYS.
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS ONCE EVERY EIGHT
DAYS -- THIS.
BILL WILL CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM
FOR TECHNOLOGY THAT -- ENABLES
FAST AND EFFICIENT CONTACT
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL UNDER ASSAULT
AND RELATED -- LAW ENFORCEMENT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE JUST
LEAVE YOU WITH ONE EDITORIAL
COMMENT.
I HAVE -- BEEN A LOBBYIST HERE
AT THE CAPITOL SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND I'VE WORKED ON A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS AND BILLS.
THIS ONE IS VERY EXCITING
BECAUSE IT PROMISES TO CREATE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'LL MAKE SCHOOLS --
SAFER I WOULD REMIND THE CHAIR
THAT BOTH OUR HIGH SCHOOL ALMA
MATERS HAVE BEEN THE UNFORTUNATE
VICTIMS OF ACT IMAGE OF ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENTS.
OF THIS IS IN A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU OKAY AT THAT THERE WAS
SOMEONE ELSE WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
MAYBE NOT OKAY SOUNDS GOOD --
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
LISTED MISTER LACKEY OKAY -- SO
YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR GRANT AS FOR
FIVE MILLION.
YES AND IT'S TO DEVELOP SOME
INTER OPERATE OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGY.OF FOUR OF K. TWELVE TO POST
SECONDARY CORRECT OKAY ALL RIGHT
THEN -- AND ANDI ASSUME THAT IS
ENOUGH BASED ON SOME
[inaudible]
OR SOME.
PLAN YES THOUGH IT ABSOLUTELY IS
YOU KNOW THE DATA IS IS IS OUT
THERE WE JUST NEED TO DEVELOP A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER AND MAKE SURE
THAT ARE YOU KNOW OUR TEACHERS
AND OUR STUDENTS KNOW HOW TO USE
IT PROPERLY.
BUT IT IS -- THE THE PROCESS IN
THE THE FRAMEWORK IS ALREADY IN
PLACE WE JUST NEED TO EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT WHAT IS IT.
HERE I GO WHAT IS IT.
MADAM CHAIR LACKEY.
NO OKAY MADAM CHAIR OF VERY
BRIEFLY.
THIS IS IN OUR OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S ABOUT SIX OR
SEVEN COMPANIES THAT DO THIS NOW.
AND THE WAY IT WORKS IS IF A
SCHOOL HAS THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AT THEIR CAMPUS WHEN THERE IS AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT.
SOMEONE WHO WORKS AT THE SCHOOL
CAN SIMPLY ENTER.
A SOFT PANIC BUTTON ON THEIR
CELL PHONE OKAY AND IT
IMMEDIATELY CONNECTS THE SCHOOLS
AUDIO AND VISUAL SERVICES WITH
THE SURROUNDING.
FIRST RESPONDER PUBLIC SAFETY --
ORGANIZATIONS -- AND THROUGH
SOME TECHNOLOGY THAT ESCAPES ME --
PART OF THIS I NEED A SIX YEAR
OLD FOR THIS PART OF IT PART OF
IT -- EVEN CAN CONVERT THOSE
CELLPHONES.
IN.
TWO PROVIDERS OF ADDITIONAL
VILLAGE VISUAL AND AUDIO ACCESS
TO FIRST RESPONDERS OKAY THERE'S
ABOUT A THOUSAND OF THEM
OPERATING IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY INEXPENSIVE
THE THE REQUEST HERE IS FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PUT THAT IN --
TO UGH CONTEXT FLORIDA HAS A
SIMILAR PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW IN
THE FLORIDA LEGISLATURE. TO DO
THE SAME THING. FOUR THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS OKAY IT'S
INCREDIBLY EFFICIENT OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND IT NOW OKAY LITTLE
BIT ABOVE MY PAY GRADE BUT I
THINK I GET IT DOWN BECAUSE WE
KEEP.
YOU GETS IN INTEROPERATES ALSO
OKAY WHATEVER SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT BUT I ASSUME IT
WAS TIED TO SOMETHING THAT WE
HAD ACCESS TO WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
OUR CELL PHONES.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU HAVE ANOTHER PROPOSAL.
YES MADAM CHAIR.
I ASKED WE CONSIDER PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO STANISLAUS
COUNTY TO IMPROVE COMMUNICATIONS
AND COORDINATION BETWEEN LOCAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THIS MONEY WOULD BE USED UPGRADE
OUT OF DATE RADIO INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT FAILS TO MEET STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS. FIVE HOURS
OF MY DISTRICT ARE FACING OUT
DIG IN FAILING COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM THAT IS CRITICAL NEED OF
THAT IS IN CRITICAL NEED OF
REPLACEMENT THIS ISSUE IS NOT
LOCALIZED TO ONE DEPARTMENT.
CERTAIN USERS OR RADIO EQUIPMENT
BUT AS BECOME WIDESPREAD.
GIVEN THAT OUR FACTORIES ARE IT
SO INADEQUATE AND NO LONGER
SERVICEABLE THAT THE ADVENT OF A
COMPLETE FAILURE OUR FIRE
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE LEFT WITHOUT
ANY MEANS OF COMMUNICATION AND
NO WAY TO UPGRADE. TO MORE
MODERN TECHNOLOGY HERE TO
TESTIFY YOUR BRIEF TEST MOST
MODESTO FIRE DEPARTMENT OF
VISION CHIEF MICHAEL LILY.
WE'RE RESTRICTING COMMENTS A
VERY BRIEF OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE FIRE SERVICE STANISLAUS
COUNTY IS OPERATING A
COMMUNICATION FOR STRUCTURE THAT
IS OUTDATED IN THE RADIOS THAT
WE USE IN THE FIELD HAVE BEEN
DETERMINED BY THE MANUFACTURE TO
BE AT THEIR END OF LIFE.
HAVE DEPARTMENTS THAN THE COUNTY
THAT ARE OPERATING ON RADIOS
THAT NOT MEET THE P. TWENTY FIVE
STANDARDS AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT OPERATE ON DIFFERENT
FREQUENCIES. TO WEAR FIRE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN STANISLAUS
COUNTY CANNOT EVEN COMMUNICATE
AMONGST EACH OTHER.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY HAVE BEEN
WORKING THE LAST COUPLE YEARS TO
BEGIN TO UPDATE THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RADIOS AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE LOST OUR
INTER OPERABILITY AND THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY.
CURRENTLY OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
LACKS COVERAGE PROVIDE ADEQUATE
BUILDING PENETRATION THERE ARE
TIMES OF FIREFIGHTERS OPERATING
INSIDE OF A BUILDING -- MONEY
INVEST BECAUSE OR ON FIRES HAVE
TO GO OUTSIDE THE BUILDING IN
ORDER.
TO RECEIVE A SIGNAL IN ORDER TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE OF THE
COMMUNICATION CENTER OR OTHER
FIREFIGHTERS OPERATING AT THE
SCENE.
THE SAFETYAN OPERA INTER
OPERABILITY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN COORDINATION WITH
THE STANCE US REGIONAL NINE ONE
ONE CENTER.
IN THE STANISLAUS COUNTY FIRE
CHIEFS COMMUNICATIONS
SUBCOMMITTEE THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE NEEDS OF THE FIRE SERVICE
IS OUR TOP PRIORITY.
THE FIRE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY LACK THE FUNDING TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNICATION THAT'S THE SAFETY
OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
APPRECIATE TO YOUR HEARING US
HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
I WAS TRYING TO GET SOME CLARITY
YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING SOME NINE
ONE ONE THINGS STATEWIDE AND SO
I WAS WANTING THIS WAS.
COVERED UNDERNEATH IT -- OKAY SO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON A LOT
OF THIS WERE SEEN AS COMING TIME
AND TIME AGAIN RIGHT NOW AND
GOVERNOR TO HIM IN HIS BUDGET
HAS.
MONEY SET ASIDE FOR STATE
AGENCIES RIGHT ON THIS IS FOR
OUR SOME OF OUR LOCAL FOLKS THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCE AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL TO FIX WHAT WE
SO DESPERATELY NEED.
ANY QUICK COMMENTS.
OKAY ANY -- ANYONE FROM THE
AUDIENCE ANY STATEMENTS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YEAH I KNOW THAT -- SEVERAL
AREAS HAVE REQUESTED THAT -- AND
SOME OF THEM DO IT WITHIN THEIR
OWN COUNTY SO AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS WELL HAVE TO HAVE
CERTAIN RADIO FREQUENCIES AND
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF THAT'S NOT.
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR GETTING
MESSAGES OUT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME THANK
YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE MISSED Và
BAUER-KAHAN HERE OF MEMBERS WHO
WHO HAD PROPOSALS DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE TO SHOW UP WITH A MESSAGE.
TO YOU HAD A PROPOSAL HE'S HERE
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER AND COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT STAND THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA ILLEGAL
DUMPING PILOT PROJECT.
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE SEE THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WHEN
WE PRESENTED BEFORE POLICY
COMMITTEE MISTER LACKEY AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SPOKE UP ABOUT HOW PREVALENT
THIS IS THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S ALSO AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IMPACTING THE SENSE OF WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN AND OTHER
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE IT'S RAMP
AND THE PEOPLE JUST DUMP --
THINGS OUT THE COMMUNITIES
UNSCRUPULOUS COMMERCIAL HAULERS
SAVE SIGNIFICANT MONEY BY
ILLEGALLY DUMPING.
CONSTRUCTION DEBRIS DIRT
ETCETERA WELL TAXPAYERS PICK UP
THE TAB TO GO CLEAN UP THE
SIGNIFICANT COST TO CLEAN UP
THESE TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
GARBAGE DUMP UNDER CITY STREETS
HIGHWAYS PARKS WATERWAYS AND
OTHER LANDS.
THE CURRENT LACK OF
INVESTIGATION INTO ILLEGAL
DUMPING CRIMES HAS LED TO AN
OVERALL LACK OF ENFORCEMENT OF
OUR ILLEGAL DUMPING LAWS WHICH
IS ENCOURAGED THE NORMALIZATION
OF THIS ACT.
OTHER CITIES COMMONLY RECEIVE
INVESTIGATIVE LEADS RELATING TO
LEADING.
RELATING TO THIS ILLEGAL DUMPING
FOR THE PUBLIC MANY POLICE
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE THE TIME OR
THE RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE THE
LEADS BECAUSE THEY'RE FOCUSED ON
VIOLENT CRIMES AND MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSES.
ILLEGAL DUMPING INVESTIGATIONS
ARE TYPICALLY TIME CONSUMING
BECAUSE EVEN IF A SUSPECT AND
LICENSE PLATE ARE CAPTURED BY
VIDEO THE SUSPECT IS COMMONLY
NOT THE REGISTERED OWNER OF THE
ASSOCIATIVE VEHICLE.
THE INVESTIGATIONS REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FOLLOW UP.
TO DEVELOP SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
TO FILE A CRIMINAL COMPLAINT.
OR CITATION.
THIS PILOT WILL ALLOW THE
FUNDING OF TWO FULL TIME
OFFICERS ONE EACH COUNTY WORKING
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO BUILD
NETWORKS INVESTIGATE AND STOP
ILLEGAL DUMPING.
AT THE END OF THE ONE YOU'RE
PILOTS AND THEY WOULD REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE HOPE IS
THAT THIS WILL SET UP A PROGRAM
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ILLEGAL
DUMPING PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL AND STOP THE
RAMPANT BEHAVIOR THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THE SPECIAL
ITEM [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS SUPPORT FROM THE
PUBLIC.
YOU WAS WONDERFUL.
OF WHICH TO CHOOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF FOR
HEARING I REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FUNDING FOR
A PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO OFFER
INMATES.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS.
THOSE WITH A HISTORY OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR SICKENING
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER REPRESENTED
IN OUR JAILS AS A RAND STUDY A
FEW YEARS AGO FOUND -- THAT 58%
OF ALL INMATESREPORTED A
PROBLEM WITH DRUG ADDICTIONS USE
OR DEPENDENTS.
NUMEROUS STUDIES OF MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT SHOW THAT IT
IS VERY EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION
THAT COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL SAVINGS MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT.
INVOLVES A COMBINATION OF
SPECIFIC MEDICATIONS AS WELL AS
OTHER SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TRYING.
TO LEAVE -- THEIR ADDICTIONS.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THE
PROVIDING MATT TO EVERY
CALIFORNIAN WHO IS RECEIVING
TREATMENT FOR OPIATE USE WOULD
RESULT IN A THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR SAVINGS RELATED
TO STE LESTER EXPENDITURES WHEN
IT COMES TO CRIME.
HEALTHCARE HIV TREATMENT EXCEPT
FOR NEWER STUDIES HAVE ALSO
SHOWN THAT MATT COULD REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WHICH RESULTS IN EVEN
MORE COST SAVINGS WITH THAT I
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO KAREN
LÏNG REPRESENTING THE CITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO. TO TESTIFY
HOW THIS PILOT PROGRAM COULD
ASSIST MY CITIES RESIDENTS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER THANK YOU FOR HAVING US --
TODAY THANK YOU MISTER TOO FOR
BRINGING THIS OPPORTUNITY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AT MARYLAND AND
BREED HAS ASKED THAT WE
REPRESENT HER IN SUPPORT TODAY.
ABOUT 80% OF THE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND BOOKINGS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY JAIL OR PERSONS WITH AN
OPIOID -- OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE AYE
DISORDER THEY ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES NOW THAT CITY COUNTY
SOME SCHOOL DOES PROVIDE SOME
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES IN THE
JAIL BUT THEY CAN'T DO IT ALONE
AND AND FRANKLY IT'S VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO FIND A
WAY TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT PARTNERING WITH
THE STATE THROUGH MEDI CAL TO
FUND THIS IMPORTANT TREATMENT IN
THE JAIL COULD ACTUALLY PROVIDE
NOT ONLY.
LIFESAVING SERVICES TO THE THE
INMATES THAT ARE THERE BUT ALSO
LOWER THE COST OVERALL TO THE
SYSTEM THAT IS PROVIDING THEM
SERVICES BEFORE AND AFTER
THEY'VE BEEN IN THE JAIL AND I
THINK THIS COULD WORK BEST FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE WOULD.
URGE YOUR PRIVILEGED APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY OKAY THANK YOU
THIS IS A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM.
YES THAT'S WHAT IT IS OKAY --
OKAY THIS REPORT.
YES IS THIS PILOT PROGRAM OF
BEING CONDUCTED SAN FRANCISCO
ONLY.
IT IS ALL THE WE INITIALLY
PROPOSED IT TO BE STATEWIDE --
AND IT WAS NARROWED IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE BUT WE ARE TALKING TO
OTHER COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND
OUR HOPE IS THAT -- THERE WILL
LIKELY BE OTHERS THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF EXPANDING IT --
WHICH WERE VERY OPEN TO WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF MY CITY
BUT IF YOU ARE OTHER CITIES ARE
INTERESTED HAPPY INCLUDING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THIS IS
FIVE BILLION FOR ONE ONE PILOT
PROGRAM IN THE BAY AREA.
ENOUGH.
THAT'S CORRECT AGAIN OBVIOUSLY
THE NUMBER DEPENDING ON WHO ALSO
IS INTERESTED COULD CHANGE THAT
OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
MUCH OF A MENTOR [inaudible]
THE MISS RUBIO HERE YES OKAY
FINE THANK YOU.
WHICH IS.
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF FOR
LONG ME TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON
THE IMPORTANCE IT THE IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
OUGHT WE ARE ASKING FOR A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR OF ON GOING
FUNDING FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
OUGHT WE MUST INVEST IN
STRATEGIC AND STRATEGIES TO
PREVENT DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT HAPPENS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HELP FUND PROGRAMS
THAT TEACH YOUTH ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE CHEAPER FOR THE
STATE IN THE LONG RUN.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALSO GOING TO
BE ABLE TO HELP WITH OUR OVERALL
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ADVOCATES WILL CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP SUSTAINED REPORTING ON
THE PROGRESS AND THE EFFICACY OF
THESE PROJECTS AND RESEARCH
ALTERNATIVE INTERVENTIONS
OUTSIDE OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE CRISTINA
MEMSIC FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND JOHN FINLEY FROM --
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL SOUGHT TO GIVE MORE
INFORMATION ON OUR PREVENTION
SERVICES THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO GOES ALL
RIGHT.
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING US SPEAK
TODAY AND FOR HEARING OUR
REQUEST MY NAME IS JOHN
LANCASTER FINLEY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO AND SENATOR
BILLS REQUEST FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT SEXUAL AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
TELL COST IS THE STATE COALITION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FOUR RICK
RICK RAPE CRISIS CENTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND A NATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ENDING SEXUAL VIOLENCE
WHEREVER IT MAY OCCUR.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB IN
CALIFORNIA OF EXPANDING OUR
SAFETY NET WHEN IT COMES TO
INTERVENING AND RESPONDING TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL
LEADER IN SO MANY WAYS BUT WE'RE
BE WHERE WE HAVE BEEN FALLING
BEHIND IS IN PREVENTING SEXUAL
ASSAULT BEFORE IT EVER HAPPENS.
WE KNOW THAT IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
TAKING A SINGLE SNAPSHOT OF THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
TOTAL COSTS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
IN THE STATE OR NEARLY A HUNDRED
AND FORTY BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS REPRESENTS TANGIBLE COSTS
THINGS LIKE MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE COUNSELING SERVICES
AND PROSECUTION AS WELL AS
INTANGIBLE COST THINGS LIKE LOST
WAGES AND LOCK LOST WORK
PRODUCTIVITY OVERTIME.
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO PREVENT A
SINGLE SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE
STATE WE CAN SAVE CALIFORNIANS
OVER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN COSTS?
INVESTING IN PREVENTION MAKES
SENSE AS A WISE LONG TERM USE OF
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS AND OUR
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITIES
ARE READY AND WILLING TO EXPAND
THE PREVENTION WORK IF GIVEN THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
TO DO SO.
IT'S TIME WE CHANGE THE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA FUNDS FOR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION FROM ZERO
DOLLARS AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE ALSO NOT GO BACKWARDS ON OR
FUNDING FOR SERVICES.
THAT'S WHY THIS BUDGET ASK ALSO
INCLUDE THE RE AUTHORIZATION OF
LAST YEAR'S ONE TIME FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING OF RATE
OF THE RAPE CRISIS PROGRAM.
SEXUAL ASSAULT IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA ONE OF THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS COMMITTED TO
PRIORITIZING AND TO ENDING.
IN OUR STATE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR STATES VALUES
IN INVESTING IN PREVENTION MUST
BE A TOP PRIORITY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS AND HOPE
TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CUSTOMS I QUIT
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS TO
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE'RE THE
STATEWIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COALITION REPRESENTING THE
AGENCIES SERVING WITH SURVIVORS --
ALL ACROSS THE STATE I HAVE JUST
A COUPLE OF ITEMS ALL ADD TO
WITH RESPECT TO THE THIS BUDGET
REQUEST IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD ON AND CONTINUE.
THE INVESTMENT THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE MADE THAT LAST
YEAR WITH FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR RAPE CRISIS CENTERS AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PREVENTION -- PRIOR TO
LAST YEAR THE STATE GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT HAD BEEN ZERO DOLLARS
FOR SEXUAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND ONLY FORTY FIVE THOUSAND FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
WE KNOW THIS LEGISLATURE STANDS
WITH SURVIVORS AND IT'S TIME FOR
US TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE --
AT THIS STAGE WE ARE REALLY AT
AN OPPORTUNE MOMENT -- TO REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE RIGHT NOW THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
BEEN ABLE TO INVEST TIME AND
ENERGY INTO A RANGE OF RESEARCH
THAT HAS POINTED THE WAY TOWARDS
PROMISING PRACTICES TOWARD
STRATEGIES AND APPROACHES THAT.
HAVE BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO HAVE A
REAL IMPACT THE KNOWLEDGE IS
THERE ABOUT WHAT WORKS THE WILL
IS THERE FROM THE ORGANIZATIONS
LOOKING TO DO THIS WHAT'S NEEDED
IS THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THAT
TIME AND COMMITMENT.
WE KNOW THAT.
RIGHT NOW WITH THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME THAT WAS
INCLUDED LAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN.
A LEVIN DIFFERENT AGENCIES
FUNDED TO DO THIS WORK ALL
ACROSS THE STATE -- FROM
PROGRAMS LIKE PARA LOS NINOS AND
LOS ANGELES TO CENTER COMMUNITY
SOLUTIONS DOWN IN SAN DIEGO A
WHOLE RANGE OF STRATEGIES AND
APPROACHES AGAIN INFORMED BY THE
EVIDENCE OF WHAT WE KNOW WORKS.
WITH THIS INVESTMENT WE CAN MAKE
SUSTAINS DIFFERENCE TO UNDER
THIS PERVASIVE ISSUE OF SEXUAL
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
HEY ANY OF THE COMMENTS FROM
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE QUESTIONS
FROM HERE MISTER LACKEY YEAH
CLEARLY THIS IS A ON AN ISSUE
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS -- TO SEE
THE IMPROVEMENT UPON HOWEVER.
THAT'S PRETTY HIGH FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS A PRETTY STRONG
AMOUNT AND THERE SEEMS TO BE.
VERY MINIMAL DETAILS WISE IS SO
COSTLY.
AS TO WHY THE THE ASK ITSELF IS
FIFTY MILLION YEAH THAT'S THE
AMOUNT SO ARE OR CALCULUS WAS
THAT WE WANTED TO MATCH WHAT THE
STATE'S.
INVESTMENT IN RESPONSE
INTERVENTION SERVICES HAS BEEN
THUS FAR WITH AN INVESTMENT IN
PREVENTING SEXUAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BEFORE THEY EVER
HAPPENED SO RIGHT NOW THERE IS --
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS GOING
TOWARD THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALSO
ADMINISTERED BY CALLOW YES ON
AND THAT IS A RESPONSE AN
INTERVENTION AND IS ALSO FEDERAL
MONEY THAT COMES IN AND THAT
MONEY DOES NOT IS NOT ABLE TO GO
TO PREVENTION FROM THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME ACT.
AND THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THEY CAN PROBABLY SAY
MORE ABOUT WHY I THAT THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S THE REASON NO.
OKAY.
I GUESS WHAT WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR IS WERE WITH THAT MONEY
DIRECTLY GO TO WRITE WHAT WHERE
WE FIND SO MANY THINGS WAS SO.
SUCH LITTLE DETAIL.
AND IT'S I THINK THAT'S OUR JOB
IS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY.
WHAT'S THE FARE CLASS IN ORDER
TO DO SO WE NEED DETAILS AND SO
IT BE HELPFUL FOR US.
TO I I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
FIGHTING.
FUNDING THIS BUT IF YOU GO TO
HIGH.
YEP THERE'S PROBLEMS YEAH WHEN
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET YOU A MORE
DETAIL ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED THE SHORT ANSWER
IS THEY'D BE.
I'M COMPETITIVE GRANTS THROUGH
HELLO YES -- ELIGIBLE TO PROGRAM
SERVING DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE -- SURVIVORS OR THEIR
COMMUNITIES -- ALREADY WORKING
ON PREVENTION SO THAT THEY HAVE
A TRACK RECORD OF KNOWING THIS
ISSUE.
WE THINK THAT WITH FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO SATURATE -- AND DO MEANINGFUL
PREVENTION WORK ACROSS THE STATE
BUT WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE AND MAKE SURE YOU ALL
HAVE THE DETAILS YOU NEED I JUST
THINK MORE DETAILS CREATURES OR
STRONGER ARGUMENT FOR THAT THAT
AMOUNT.
AND BECAUSE THAT IS A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT RIGHT NOW
ABSOLUTELY AND AND IF I MAY UM
YOU KNOW WITH THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THIRTEEN AGENCIES WERE
FUNDED AND SELL.
THE HOPE IS THAT WE CAN EXPAND
THAT NOW IF YOU MULTIPLY IT'S
ANOTHER.
OF POSSIBLY UP TO A HUNDRED
AGENCIES WE HAVE A LOT OF
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING --
PROVIDED IN A THE THE LARGE
COUNTIES AND THE HOPE IS THAT WE
CAN -- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES IN THE RURAL COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE KIND OF THE
ROBUST -- SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE IN LA COUNTY
AND SOUL SOUL YES THE FIFTY
MULTI MILLION DOLLARS IS --
QUITE SIGNIFICANT -- BY I ALSO
FOUND THAT SOME OF THESE --
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE COMPETITIVE
AND THE GRANT SELECTION PROCESS
AND I THINK THAT'S ALSO AN ISSUE
AND YOU KNOW I WOULD BE.
OBVIOUSLY GET THE INFORMATION
FOR YOU BUT I THINK IF WE CAN
HELP SOME OF THOSE RURAL
COMMUNITIES ALSO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT MONEY THAT WOULD
HELP AND I THINK THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS.
IS IS APPROPRIATE BUT I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AND I KNOW.
NOW THAT THIS IS MY THIRD YEAR
THAT THE THE HIGHER YOU GO THE
LESS LIKELY WOULD GET FUNDED BY --
WE ARE PUTTING A LOT OF EMPHASIS
ON SURVIVORS AND WHICH IS
APPROPRIATE BUT I ALSO FOUND
THAT -- A LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T
INVEST IN THE PREVENTION PART OF
OF THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SO
I MY HOPE IS THAT WE SUPPORT
BOTH THE PREVENTION PART AS WELL
AS THE SURVIVOR PARTS OF THAT --
THE SURVIVOR PART PART
EVENTUALLY GETS -- LESS AND LESS --
THERE'S LESS AND LESS NEED
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING A LOT MORE
IN THE PREVENTION PART
[inaudible]
OKAY I'M -- RIGHT WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE PROPOSED IS ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES IS WHEN WE GET A
PROPOSAL THIS SIZE IS THAT WE
PROBABLY.
WE ALWAYS BELIEVE WE NEED A LOT
MORE DETAIL RIGHT AS I WAS WHERE
THE MONEY'S GOING IN EVEN IF IF
WE'RE DEALING WITH -- AGENCIES
THAT DON'T HAVE MUCH
INFRASTRUCTURE SOMETIMES THAT.
IT IS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
FUND BECAUSE THEY MAY NOT HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT OR TO MANAGE OR THE
VALUE WAIT.
PROGRAM SO THAT BECOMES ANOTHER
BIOLOGIST WHETHER THEY'RE GOING
TO BE THE STANDALONE A WEATHER
GOING TO BE AN UMBRELLA.
THAT THAT HAS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO TO DO THE GRANT TO DO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF IT SOMETIMES
WE GIVE MONEY TO AGENCIES -- AND
HOPE THE BILL DO SOME GOOD WORK
IN THERE AND AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT EVEN DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THEIR BEST EFFORTS SO THAT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME THINGS THAT
ARE HERE -- AND AND I KNOW THAT.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED IN SO ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES I FIND WITH WITH MOST
OF OUR PROPOSALS IS THAT --
WHAT'S HOT WE HAVE A LOT OF
THINGS IS GOING ON IN THE STATE
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS WELL
COORDINATED.
BY YOU KNOW WE DO A LOT OF
THINGS AND SO AS WE SAY YOU KNOW
WITHIN TEETH SAFE AND HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP SKILLS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT -- THAT'S ALSO PART OF
A HEALTHY KIDS ACTIVE OF OF OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO IT WOULD DO
ONE THAT AT THAT LEVEL HOW DOES
THAT INTERFACE WITH WHAT'S GOING
ON OVER HERE.
AND ON AND YOU KNOW SO IT'S IT'S
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT THINK.
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT -- LIKE THE ISSUE
OF HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS OR OR
OR THIS CASE WITH DEALING WITH --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WHAT HAVE YOU YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
ALREADY.
AND HOW DO WE COMPLEMENT THAT
AND THEN HOW DO WE MATCH THAT
WITH OUR OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ALSO RAISE
MONEY SO THAT IF OUR AGENCIES
ARE DOING THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
SAY THAT ARE THERE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT OF THE YEAR.
THEN.
OBVIOUSLY THERE THEY BELIEVE
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL NEEDS TO
FOR EXPANSION SO HOW DOES THAT
ALSO MATCH WITH YOU KNOW SAN
DIEGO'S PROGRAMS AT THE TO THE
WHY THEY GETS MONEY.
FOR A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
ASSAULT AND SO WE'RE DOING THAT
WORK IS THAT IS THE WORK.
HALF BEING DONE AND THERE'S A
GREATER NEED THIS THERE ARE YOU
KNOW WHAT SO I THINK A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
DISCUSSION OF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL -- AS WE TALK ABOUT
MEETING CERTAIN NEEDS AND HAVING
OTHER NEEDS ARE NOT MET YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THE WORK ON THIS AREA IS
GOING FORWARD BUT MAYBE NOT AS
AS MUCH AS WE'D LIKE.
WITH THE YOU KNOW THE PERCEPTION
IS THAT WE SHOULD REACH MORE
INDIVIDUALS IF WE'RE GOING TO DO --
EDUCATION -- ARE WE GOING TO DO
IT IN THE SCHOOL TO WORK WITH
AND I WOULD HOUSING HAPPENING SO
I THINK WHEN WHEN WE GET A
PROPOSAL THIS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE JOIN US ON THIS MUCH MORE
FLESHED OUT THEY DON'T THAN
SOMEONE WHO ASKS THE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TWO MILLION WHAT
DO REAL SWIMMING POOL YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO GIVE THEM
A COMMUNITY.
SO LIKE THAT IS A LOT SOMETIMES
IT'S EASIER TO IDENTIFY THEN IF
WE'VE GOT A COORDINATED PROJECT
AND AS SOON.
THE FIFTY MILLION GHOST OH YES
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
IT IS ADMINISTERED OUT.
OKAY OKAYED BY HOME I OH YES.
WITH THE PROPOSES THEY GO OKAY
AND SO THEN IN THE END WHO
ASSESSES WHAT HAPPENS.
SO ALL OF THE GRANT TO THE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE REGULAR
PROGRESS REPORTS TO HELLO YES OF
OKAY ACTIVITY IS AND THEN THAT'S
INCLUDED WITH THEN -- YESES --
BIG REPORT THAT I KNOW YOU ALL
GET BACK FROM THEM EVERY YEAR
AND THEIR BUDGET COMMITTEE
REPORT YEAH BUT IT'S SO YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU PUT YOUR POLLS
WHEN IS NICE TO PULL OUT YOUR
PAGE AND PUT IT WITH IT.
SO THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY BECAUSE
THE DISCUSSION WHERE IF IF IF
YOU'RE PART OF YOUR PROPOSAL IS
THAT.
YOU MAY THIS REQUEST BAY AND
BASED ON WHAT YOU DID LAST YEAR
THIS IS THE SUCCESS WE SHOW.
THAT'S TAKEN PLACE AND THIS SHOW
STILL BE A NEED SO THEN WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE SAID OKAY YEAH
THEY'VE DONE IT LET'S PUSH FOR
LET'S DO SOME MORE.
AND THAT BECOMES IMPORTANT IN A
IN US ASSESSING THE AMOUNT THAT
THAT FOLKS ARE ASKING FOR YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE YEAR AND WE
BELIEVE EVERYBODY'S DOING GOOD
WORK BUT WE JUST SOME WHEN YOU
GOT COMPETING INTERESTS.
AND YOU HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF WE
INCREASE RESOURCES THAT WERE
GIVEN SOMEONE THAT THEY'VE DONE
WELL WITH THE AMOUNT WE GIVE
THEM AND THAT THERE'S A
RATIONALE FOR INCREASING.
THE DOLLARS THAT GO FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY DR WEBBER -- I AGREE
WITH YOU I HAVE A BILL CURRENTLY
AND TO TO MAKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS EVIDENCE
BASED BUDGETING IS WHAT WE WERE
CALLING IT.
BECAUSE THAT IS MORE BECAUSE I
SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION WITH WITH --
YOU KNOW I I IT'S FRUSTRATING TO
ME WE PIECEMEAL EVERYTHING AND
SOMETIMES -- YOU KNOW I CAME
INTO THIS PLACE IT'S THIS IS MY
THIRD YEAR AND THAT IS THE
FRUSTRATION THAT THE THE OUT
FACT THAT SOME OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT CONNECTED.
IN SIMILAR -- BEETLE ISSUES I I
OFTEN SPEAK AND AS AS SOMEONE
THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOW I WAS A TEACHER AND THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IS COMPLETELY
DISCONNECTED FROM THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM INSTEAD OF COORDINATING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOSTER
KIDS ARE.
ARE RECEIVING THE PROPER --
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED FROM THE
SCHOOLS WE OPERATE AND SIDLES
SOUL POINT WELL TAKEN WE WILL GO
BACK AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE ALL OF THOSE DETAILS OUT
FOR YOU AND WE WON'T WILL CALL
IT -- EVIDENCE BASED --
BUDGETING IN THIS CASE SO THAT
WE CAN OR EVIDENCE I'LL BE YOUR
DO IT BUT NO WAY OKAY SO EVIDENT
EVEN.
SITE AND VERIFICATION YES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU KNOW BECAUSE
AS WE HAVE SAID ON THE
ACCOUNTABILITY WANTING THERE'S
ALL KIND OF LET'S BE AMENABLE TO
FOR THE MONEY THAT WE WE HAD
LAST YEAR AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN --
INCREASE IT BASED ON THE SUCCESS
OF OF THE LAST TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT DOUBT WILL YOU
GRACIOUSLY -- BUT COMMITTEE
APPROVED FOR US THANK YOU AND SO
I GUESS IT'S A WE'RE WORKING ON
ON ON ON THE REALITY THAT ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT SO THEN THE QUESTION
BECOMES HOW DO WE MATCH IT.
AND HOW WE MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATING SERVICES THAT
ALREADY EXIST AND THAT'S MY ONLY
THING IS THAT IS NOT SUBJECT TO
EVEN THINK THAT THE PART I DON'T.
GET IT I DON'T LISTEN TO BLAME
THE DEPARTMENT I JUST KNOW THAT
QUITE OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS IS WE
GET A LOT OF PROPOSALS RIGHT TO
COME IN. FOR VARIOUS THINGS AND
WITHOUT THINKING BACK TO SAY DO
WE ALREADY DO THAT IF WE DO HOW
WELL DO WE DO IT AND HOW MUCH OF
IT IS BEING DONE IS THIS GOING
TO BE AUGMENTED WITH THAT VERSES
THAT.
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR OWN PROPOSAL
IN OWN IDEAS AND SO WE FIND
OURSELVES SOMETIMES PROGRAMS
DUPLICATING EACH OTHER OR EVEN
NOT EVEN THAT ABLE TO DETERMINE
HOW MUCH WE'RE GIVING A HOW MUCH
ARE WE DOING IN CERTAIN AREAS --
IT'S BECOMES EVEN MORE
COMPLICATED BECAUSE BECAUSE
PROGRAMS HAVE DIFFERENT NAMES
AND I JUST HAD SOMEONE TODAY
THIS MORNING TELL ME ABOUT A
PROGRAM.
AND I THINK I SEE IT ARE WE ARE
REDOING A PROGRAM UNDER SO AND
SO SO ONCE ON CONFINED IT WAS
THE SAME PROGRAM.
BUT IT HAD A SUBTITLE.
AND A PERSON DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE
ACTUALLY FUNDING THIS PROGRAM
BUT IT WAS UNDER SUBTITLE SO HE
WE WERE BEING ASKED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE WHATEVER
WAS MILLION.
ON A PROGRAM THAT YOU KNOW I I
FORGET THE EXACT AMOUNT BUT YOU
KNOW WAS WE WERE ALREADY KIND OF
DOING IT WE WERE.
AND AND AND HE HAD JUST PULLED
UP THE SUBTITLE OF THE PROGRAM
WITHOUT REALIZING IT WAS IT WAS
THE WHEN I READ IT I WAS LIKE
I'VE READ THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE --
SO MY GOD NO WE GAVE SOME MONEY
TO THIS BEFORE AND KIND OF FIND
IT IT WAS THE SAME PROPOSAL BUT
IT HAD A NEW TITLE SO -- YOU
KNOW I THINK SOMETIMES MAYBE IN
THAT MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD DO IS BUTTE REALLY BEGIN
TO LOOK AT ALL THE STUFF WITH.
ONE AND FIVE SO THAT WHEN A
MEMBER DECIDES I WANT.
TO DO A. B. C. THEN AT LEAST
THEY CAN GO IN AND AND FIND AT
ABC HAS HAS BEEN FUNDED AT ONE
LEVEL BUT NEED NOT TAKE IT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL WHICH IS RIGHT
YOU KNOW WHICH IS ALL LEGIT BUT
ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO.
MUCH FOR EVERYBODY TIME AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND PROVIDE ALL
THOSE DETAILS TO NO PROBLEM YOU
HAD ANOTHER FOR POSTAL
ENFORCEMENT TEAMS.
IS THAT THE SAME THING NO.
AB ONE OH NINE ENFORCEMENT TEAM
YES WE WILL -- BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEING SUBMITTED OF AT THIS POINT
TO AYE IF WE LEAVE IT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN I MEAN WHAT
WHAT ELSE WAS I GOING TO DO SO
SO SO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE --
WHEN AB ONE OF NINE WAS -- WAS
DONE RIGHT WAS MONIES THAT WERE
BE BEING GIVING TO THE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO FIND ONE
POSITION. TO TO HELP WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND HELP WITH THE
PREVENTION -- FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CITY OF DUARTE WHERE I REPRESENT
OUT WHO I REPRESENT ON THE HAVE
A PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY TO HELP
TEENS GET OUT OF THAT AND SO
THAT MONEY RAN OUT AND SOUL THE
INTENT WAS IT'S A TWENTY MILLION
OR YESTERDAY MILLION AND WE HAD.
YES IT'S GONE YEAH DONE WELL YES
WE DID FOR SEVERAL YEARS RIDE
WAS JUST AND TWENTY AND THEN
IT'S GONE SO SOME OF MY CITIES --
I DID THE PROPOSAL LAST YEAR AND
SOME OF MY CITIES WERE SAYING
THAT THEY STILL HAVE THAT NEED
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
NOW THAT THE MONEY'S GONE.
THEY STILL WANT -- TO CONTINUE A
DECAYING THE TEEN SPECIFICALLY
TEENS I AND SO THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS AND AT THIS POINT BECAUSE OF
ALL THE PROPOSAL'S GOING ON YOU
KNOW -- I KNOW THAT -- WE HAVE
COMPETING UP BUDGET REQUESTS AT
THIS POINT I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE
OKAY BUT THAT'S WHAT IT WAS AND
SO HOPEFULLY -- IF WE HAVE MORE
MONEY AND DIED.
WE CAN LOOK AT TO SEE IF THERE'S
PROGRAMS ALREADY BEING FUNDED
THAT HELP THAT -- I CAN HELP MY
POLICE DEPARTMENTS GET SOME OF
THAT MONEY SO THAT THEY CAN --
WORK ON PREVENTION SOUNDS GOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU UHHUH.
OKAY WE'RE NOW AT A MISTER
OBERNOLTE I THINK US ON COMEY
AND YES I DID.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
HERE AS CHAIRMAN OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE CAUCUS WHICH I'M SURE
YOU'RE NO IS JUST THE INLAND
EMPIRE ****.
UP SLOWLY IS GOING THERE FOR
YEARS IT'S ACTUALLY ALMOST A
FIFTH OF THE LEGISLATURE CAUCUS
SON WHO PLAYED IN IMPERIAL NO GO
HEAD.
WE PROBABLY OUGHT.
TO GET A CUP.
OKAY WELL I LIKE TO PRESENT ONE
OF THE CAUCUS PRIORITIES FOR
THIS YEAR WHICH IS A REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE FUNDS
TWENTY FIVE JUDGESHIPS.
THOSE JUDGESHIPS WERE CREATED
OVER TEN YEARS AGO BY THE
LEGISLATURE BUT HAVE NEVER BEEN
FUNDED DESPITE SEVERAL EFFORTS.
THE INLAND EMPIRE HAS A SPECIAL
CONCERN ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THE
SPARE COURT OF SALMON YOU KNOW
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES ARE THE
TWO MOST UNDER STAFFED COUNTIES
IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND I'VE OF SOME PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS AND VERY
STRONG FEELINGS ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE BEFORE BEING ELECTED THE
ASSEMBLY WAS MAYOR OF A CITY
THAT LOST ITS COURTHOUSE DUE TO
A LACK OF JUDGES.
SO I GOT TO SEE FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACT OF THAT LACK OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE HAS ON A COMMUNITY AND I
THOUGHT WE HAD A BAD THEN BUT
NOW I REPRESENTS CITIES LIKE THE
CITY OF NEEDLES.
THAT HAS A COURTHOUSE IT'S
CLOSED IT'S SITTING THERE TO BE
PERFECTLY FINE THE EXCEPT FOR A
LACK OF JUDGES TO STEP OUT.
AND MY CONSTITUENTS NEEDLES HAVE
TO TRAVEL NOW. THREE AND A HALF
HOURS DEPENDING ON WEATHER DOT
IT'S A CRIMINAL MATTER OR A
CIVIL MATTER BUT BUT THREE THREE
AND A HALF HOURS TO COURT.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
BURDEN IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTFUL ON THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD TO TAKE A WHOLE DAY
OFF OF WORK TO ATTEND COURT.
OR CAN'T AFFORD THE
TRANSPORTATION SO -- IT'S IT'S
REALLY A DIRE ISSUE FOR US --
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME ON THAT
THIS MATTER IS JUDGE VANDERVEER
HERE IS THE PRESIDING JUDGE OF
THE SAME MEDINA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WAS HERE
LAST YEAR WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT NEEDLES AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A CAR IT'S A THIRTEEN HOUR
BUS RIDE.
IT'S THIRTEEN HOUR IN A HOT TO
BE TAKING THE BUS TO VICTORVILLE
AND TAKE THE BUS BACK IS A
THIRTEEN HOUR DAYS TO GET TO
COURT -- BUT TODAY I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT TIME --
THREE MONTHS AGO I WAS ASKED BY
THE PRESIDING JUDGE OF ANOTHER
COURT.
HOW ARE CORD HANDLES THE WORK
LOAD A LOT AND I SAID BECAUSE WE
HAVE BIG CALENDARS?
SO LAST FOR SOME STATISTICAL
DATA TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY AND
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A SNAPSHOT.
FOR FISCAL YEAR -- SEVENTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN ARE FOR JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY COURTS HEAR AN
AVERAGE FOR COURT DAY OF THIRTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT HEARINGS PER
DAY SO THAT'S JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY THIRTY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT HEARINGS ARE DAY -- FOR
CRIMINAL COURT IN RANCHO OR ONE
OF OUR LARGE CRIMINAL COURTS
THEIR HEARING FORTY FIVE POINT --
FOUR HEARINGS PER DAY FOR
VICTORVILLE WHICH IS SMALLER.
HERE'S CRIMINAL AND FAMILY LAW
THEIR HEARING THIRTY SIX POINT.
SIX ON AVERAGE HEARINGS PER DAY.
AND THAT'S HOW IT'S AN EIGHT
HOUR DAY US AVERAGE AND THEN
THAT THAT THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
LOOK AT SOME OF OUR VERY HIGH
VOLUME COURTS HANDLE SPENT THE
HIGH LOW.
HIGH VOLUME -- LET ME RIDE
THROUGH COURT OKAY OR
MISDEMEANOR DEPARTMENTS HERE AN
AVERAGE OF NINETY TO ONE HUNDRED
HEARINGS PER DAY.
OUR PHONE THE PRELIMINARY
HEARING DEPARTMENTS WHEN A
PERSON FIRST.
ARRAIGNMENT THEIR HEARING FORTY
TO FIFTY HEARINGS PER DAY --
SOLVE IT'S NOT JUST DISTANCE
IT'S TIME.
SO MANY CASES WE TRY TO GET
THROUGH THE DAY AND WE GET
THROUGH THE DAY.
THE IMPACT OF ALL THE COURTS
OPEN EVERY DAY FIVE DAYS A WEEK
FIVE DAYS A WEEK -- EIGHT THIRTY
WE START COUNTER CALLS AND WE
TRY TO FINISH AT FOUR THIRTY SO
THE CLERK HAS TIME TO FINISH THE
ELDERS.
AND THAT'S JUST THE SNAPSHOT WE
SENT ALL THE STATISTICAL DATA
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OBERNOLTE IS
OFFICE IF YOU LIKE IT WE CAN
SURE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU BUT
THAT'S JUST A TASTE A LITTLE
SNAPSHOT OF THE VOLUME THAT WE
DEAL WITH WHEN YOU'RE.
A JUDGE A COURT THAT.
AS OPPOSED TO HAVE THIRTY EIGHT
MORE JUDGES ACCORDING THE
WORKLOAD STUDY NEED SOME WHAT WE
CURRENTLY THAN WHAT WE HAVE.
OKAY.
SO THIS FUNDING REQUEST WOULD
FUND. TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED POSITIONS
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ESTIMATES
THAT.
THE CURRENT SHORTAGE OF JUDGES
CALIFORNIA IT CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE IS OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE SO TWENTY FIVE IS
JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET JUST
TO BE CLEAR EVEN THOUGH.
THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
CAUCUS.
WERE NOT DIRECTING THOSE JUDGES
TO BE JUST FOR OUR COURTS WE
WOULD GIVE THEM TO THE GENERAL
COUNSEL AT THEM ALLOCATE THEM
AND TRUST THAT SOME OF THOSE
JUDGES WOULD COME TO US AND
SOMEONE.
COME TO OTHER NEEDY PORTIONS OF
OF THE STATE BUT I WOULD HOPE
YOU AGREE THAT ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL RESPONSIBILITIES OF
STATE GOVERNMENT IS TO ENSURE
THAT ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
AND I THINK WE'RE FAILING IN
THAT DUTY TO SOME OF THESE
CONSTITUENTS SO I'D DIE REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT -- I THINK
A VERY MODEST BUDGET REQUEST
OKAY.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY IT IS -- IF YOU WANT
TO SHARE THE DATA YOU CAN BUT I
KNOW WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OKAY TH
MINISTRY WHAT IT'S THAT'S BEEN
ON FOR A WHILE.
AND AND CLEARLY THE THE TRANCE
THE JUST TRAVELING TO COURTS AS
A WAS A MAJOR ISSUE WE OPEN SOME
ADDITIONAL ONES BUT EVEN THEN --
WE ARE NOT AT A PLACE I THINK
PERSONALLY WHERE WHERE WE CAN
TRULY SAY THAT WITH EVERYONE HAS
EQUAL ACCESS. TO JUSTICE -- BUT
EVEN THOSE JUST.
THE FACT WE SHUT DOWN EVEN IN
SAN DIEGO SO MANY BY NIGHT COURT.
SO THE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO
LEAVE THEIR JOBS JUST TO DEAL
WITH TRAFFIC TICKETS OR WHATEVER
MAY BE -- YOU KNOW IS REALLY
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE MOST FOLKS
MANY FOLKS WERE IN THAT
SITUATION BUT THEY HAVEN'T PAID
THE TICKETS AND THEY'RE CAUGHT
IN IT.
THAT'S THAT CYCLE CANNOT AFFORD
TO TAKE OFF FROM WORK -- TO GO
TO COURT AND SO IT IS -- WE'RE
IN A PRETTY SAD STATE BECAUSE
THAT YOU KNOW IF IT'S NOT
ACCESSIBLE THEN IT IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
AND PEOPLE OFTEN MAKE DEALS ARE
PLEASE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO GO TO COURT.
AND A AND IT REALLY IS
UNBELIEVABLE AND UNACCEPTABLE
THAT FOLKS HAVE TO TRAVEL SO FAR.
AND SO LONG JUST TO GET TO COURT
AND WAIT SO LONG.
AND JUDGES HAVE TO HANDLE THAT
MANY CASES A DAY WHICH MEANS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN HEAR.
FOLKS IF YOU ACTUALLY WAITING
THAT LONG SO WE'LL SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO I KNOW THAT HASN'T BEEN
THE LATEST REQUEST THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN FOR MORE JUDGES IN WINDOW.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN OUR LIST OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
AND WE SHIFTED SOME FOLKS AROUND
I GUESS SOME COURTS AROUND A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND BUT I KNOW
WE BY NO MEANS GOT TO WHAT WE
NEED TO BE.
WILL LOOK AT IT APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE KEEP
BRINGING IT TO ME AND MAKE ME
FEEL BAD ABOUT [inaudible]
WELL HOPEFULLY.
WHICH WILL WORK ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND GIVE US
THE DATA IF YOU CAN GIVE IT TO
HIM YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME SO
YOU COULD WIN HERE IN SOME CASES
ON YEAH.
THAT'S OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OUR I WOULD NOT MISS RAY YES YES.
HELLO HELLO HELLO.
MADAM CHAIR YES HOW ARE YOU
TODAY VERY GOOD I'M ALSO --
BEFORE I DO MY PRESENTATION ALSO
MEMBER THE INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS
AND I WANT TO ECHO WHAT MR
OBERNOLTE SAID.
AND I APPRECIATE THE JUDGE
VANDERVEER WAS HERE.
WE DO NEED MORE JUDGES ALSO
QUESTION I KNOW YOU NEED THEM
THEY'RE JUSTICE DELAYED IS
JUSTICE DENIED NO QUESTION NO
QUESTION AND SPEAKING OF JUSTICE --
I WANT TO ADD THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME AND SPEAK TO
THE COMMITTEE ON A ON THIS
CONSIDERATION.
THE REQUEST IS FOR ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION.
AND IT WOULD ESTABLISH FUNDING
TO ENSURE THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES WHO FIND THEMSELVES
IN CHILD WELFARE RELATED CASES
HAVE BEEN LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
WHICH THEY CANNOT AFFORD.
IT'S CRUCIAL TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN ARE NOT RIPPED AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
UNNECESSARILY AND WILL INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL STANDARDS OUTLINED IN
THE INDIAN WELFARE ACTOR IT COR.
NATIONALLY THERE WERE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIX APPEALED IT
COURT CASES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AT OF THOSE.
CALIFORNIA HAD ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THE NEXT.
STATE THE SECOND STATE ARE WITH
THE HIGHEST NUMBER WAS ALASKA
WITH THE ELEVEN SO CALIFORNIA IS
DEALING WITH THE MAJORITY OF
THESE.
ACCORDING TO THE EQUIPMENT
PLANTS TASK FORCE REPORT
PRESENTED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
ESTABLISHING THIS FUND WILL
DRAMATICALLY DECREASE THE
APPEALS CALIFORNIA HAS RELATING
TO IT QUIRK AND TRIBAL CHILD
WELFARE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
WILL PROTECT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
FROM UNNECESSARY HARM AND TRAUMA.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT TO YOU I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE -- DALY A
SHARP WHO WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN THIS
REGARD.
HELLO I'M WITH A CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL FAMILIES COALITION WHICH
IS THE SUCCESSOR ORGANIZATION TO
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE TASK
FORCE I'M THAT PUT TOGETHER THE
REPORT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE I'M.
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I
HAVE TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
CASES CURRENTLY IS THAT THE
COUNTIES REPRESENTED BY AN
ATTORNEY.
AND THE MINOR IS REPRESENTED BY
AN ATTORNEY AND EACH OF THE
PARENTS ARE REPRESENTED BY AN
ATTORNEY.
BUT THE TRIBE IS OFTEN
REPRESENTED BY A SOCIAL WORKER
THE OFTEN THE ONLY SOCIAL WORKER
THAT WORKS FOR THE TRIBE THAT IS
WEARING THE HAT OF THE SOCIAL
WORKER ON THE GROUND.
RECEIVING REFERRALS OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT INVESTIGATING THOSE
REFERRALS PROVIDING SERVICES AND
THEN HAVING TO ACT AS
ESSENTIALLY A LAY ATTORNEY IN
THE COURT ROOM.
I'M BECAUSE OF THAT IN LARGE
PART I'M WHAT WE HEARD FROM
TRIBES ACROSS THE STATE WHEN
WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER THE TASK
FORCE REPORT I'M WAS THAT WE
WILL NEVER SEE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT.
AS LONG AS JUDGES AREN'T ABLE TO
HEAR IN COURT THE WAY THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT IS SUPPOSED TO
OPERATE AND I JUST AM WHAT TO
READ TO YOU BRIEFLY A QUOTE FROM
THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGES.
OF CALIFORNIA -- THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN ONE OF THEIR SUPPORT
LETTER SO YOU HAVEN'T SOLVED.
ONLY READ A A SHORT PORTION OF
IT BUT AND IT SAYS ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCIES IN
EQUITY CASES HAS BEEN THE
FAILURE OF TRIBES TO BE
REPRESENTED.
THE REASON IS SIMPLE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO HAVE AN ATTORNEY
PRESENT AT THE HEARING TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE TRIBE.
THE RESULT IS THE INTEREST OF
THE TRIBE OR NOT PRESENTED OR
ARGUED FORCEFULLY AND THE JUDGES
DENIED INFORMATION THAT WOULD
MAKE HIS OR HER DECISION MORE
ACCURATE AND COMPLIANCE WITH EC
WHAT.
THE JUDGES BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
WILL ENSURE HIGH QUALITY LEGAL
REPRESENTATION FOR THE TRIBE.
AND THAT APPELLATE COURTS WOULD
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF TRAINS
COUNCIL SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE TRIBE.
OUR JUDGES WILL BE BETTER JUDGES
WITH THE PRESENCE OF THESE
ATTORNEYS I'M AND WHEN WE WERE
PUTTING TOGETHER THE TASK FORCE
REPORT ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
WE WERE MAKING TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AT THE TIME AND
AND NOW TO YOU.
I'M IS THAT WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THIS WOULD
BE OFFSET BY THE MONEY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SPENDING -- WITH
THE TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF APPEALS
THAT WE'RE SEEING OF COURSE IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING YOU KNOW
THE APPEALS CREATE TREMENDOUS
TRAUMA IN THE LIVES OF AN INDIAN
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES --
BUT JUST IN TERMS OF OFFENDING
BECAUSE WE'RE HERE AT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
I WE DO BELIEVE THAT OVER TIME --
THE THE THE THE FUNDING WOULD
BALANCE OUT.
THANK YOU YOU MAY THIS REPORT
THE TWO ARE AG.
I'M YES THIS WAS ON A REPORT --
ATTORNEY GENERAL HARRIS BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN INVITED THE
INVITATION OF A TASK FORCE TO
LOOK AT COMPLIANCE WITH THE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT.
AND THE CONCLUSION OF THAT TASK
FORCE WAS A REPORT THAT WAS
ABOUT A HUNDRED PAGES WITH
TWENTY TARGETED REPRESENT.
TWENTY TARGETED RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SERRA IN
MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HAVE
A COPY OF THE REPORT IF YOU'D
LIKE ME TO PROVIDE IT.
UNTIL THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
ABSENT SO YOU'VE IS SO MISTER
MISTER SERRA HAS THIS REQUEST
YES OKAY.
AND I DON'T THINK HE'S NECESSARY
IT COMMUNICATED THAT TO US BUT
WE CAN CHECK ON IT.
OKAY I BELIEVE THAT HAS OFFICE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST YEAR
WHEN IT WAS BROUGHT A. B. --
THIRTY SEVENTY SIX BUT THE
NATURE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SEEMS TO BE THAT THEY
SUBMIT LETTERS OF REPORT RATHER
LATE IN THE PROCESS OF THAT CAME
ON THE SENATE SIDE.
SO AB THIRTY SEVENTY SIX IS
PASSED IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SO THAT WAS THE LAST YEAR WE
BROUGHT THE SAME BELL
UNFORTUNATELY -- WE GOT STUCK IN
A SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEVER SAW OKAY
OKAY YEAH.
AND THERE'S A BILL THIS YEAR YES.
YES IT AB [inaudible]
SIX EIGHT FIVE ALL RIGHT.
AND WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND REQUEST
THAT HE SENT HIS LETTER SUPPORT
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER OKAY
ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU IN OUT IS ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE WANTS.
TO THINK THEY'RE ALL FINE OKAY.
ANY OTHER MEMBER PRESENT TO WHO
WANTED TO PRESENT THEIR
RECOMMENDATION I THINK.
WE'VE DONE THEM ALL MY MEMORY IF
IT LOOKS LIKE.
OKAY.
LET ME THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING
IN HE'S GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO HEAR YOU PERSONALLY IN TERMS
OF YOUR REQUEST -- THAT HAVING
BEEN SAID -- I THINK THOSE THAT
SAID AND SO WE HAVE A JOURNEY
UNTIL I NEXT MEETING IS NEXT
WEEK I BELIEVE YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR COMING